volvemos para actualizaciones de las
noticias económicas con Daniel hablando
Un saludo nuevamente Daniela Bueno vamos
con sus temas en Europa panorama
económico de este año luce menos sombrío
si Ángela pues la comisión europea
actualizó su proyección de crecimiento
esto para los 27 países que conforman la
Unión Europea lo hizo hasta el 0,8% para
2023 Antes esperaba que creciera 0,3% es
decir que lo mejoró en cinco décimas
también la inflación anual hace tres
meses estimaban 7% para todo el año
ahora del 6,4% y esto viene acompañado
de otra noticia Que escucharemos a
continuación
la economía y la Unión Europea comenzó
este año con una base más saludable de
lo esperado y parece preparada para
escapar de la recesión desde otoño la
economía experimentado una serie de
desarrollos positivos el precio del gas
europeo ha caído por debajo de su nivel
anterior a la guerra ayudado por las
restricciones de la demanda la
diversificación de las fuentes de
suministro Y por supuesto el clima un
crecimiento de la producción mejor de lo
esperado a finales del año pasado y la
mejora del sentimiento económico
sugieren que la economía del bloque está
lista para escapar de la recesión
técnica que se proyectó en otoño
y sin embargo Las verdaderas ganadoras
del año pasado fueron las petroleras así
es y vamos a revisarlo con cifras en
mano el dos para nadie es un secreto fue
un año excepcional para estas compañías
ya que la guerra en Ucrania ocasionó un
alza inusitada de los precios que
llegaron a sobrepasar ampliamente los
100 dólares por barriga pues la más
grande del mundo que es la Saudita
aramco va a revelar sus resultados el 12
de marzo pero lo que conocemos hasta
ahora hasta septiembre es que iba
ganando 130 mil millones de dólares casi
el doble que un año atrás en todo el año
Epson móvil generó más de 56 mil
millones de dólares en ganancias más del
doble que el año anterior shel también
tuvo su mejor resultado en 115 años de
Historia La Noruega quinoa estuvo
momento de triplicar sus ganancias
Chevron pipi total energys y conozco
Philips también Hicieron lo propio como
podemos ver en el gráfico lo que les ha
traído lluvias de críticas pues han
estado en el foco de la opinión pública
durante varios meses Naciones Unidas
cuyo secretario general se ha referido
al tema diciendo que los combustibles
fósiles generan beneficios monstruosos
es una de esas críticas también el mismo
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
quien calificó esta situación de
Escandalosa porque denuncia que estas
empresas gastan esos rendimientos en
pagos a sus ejecutivos en lugar de
invertirlos en una mayor producción y de
esta manera bajar los precios de los
combustibles ahora también se conocieron
las cifras sobre los hidrocarburos
superó en Rusia
Así es pues lo que se conoció según el
Primer Ministro ruso es que los las
exportaciones de gas natural bajaron en
un 25% durante el año pasado pero que
dice Rusia que eso se está viendo
compensado con china porque hacia china
por el contrario estas exportaciones
subieron un 48% esto quiere decir que
está compensando todas esas ventas que
le hacía la Unión Europea y ahora pues
está buscando otros mercados como los
asiáticos bien hecha la tarea y los
indicadores Daniela El dólar está
subiendo este lunes en el mundo antes de
que se conozca el dato de inflación en
Estados Unidos para enero las bolsas
europeas por ejemplo están al alza
también está alentadas por las mejores
perspectivas de la comisión europea
sobre el crecimiento de este año de lo
que estábamos hablando las bolsas
asiáticas cerraron en rojo afectadas por
la atención geopolítica que ha generado
entre Estados Unidos y China esto por el
sobrevuelo de los supuestos globos
espías en sus territorios
ahora le pido que volvamos al dato de
inflación hoy Por qué es tan importante
Ángela porque es el que le da luces a la
reserva Federal para saber qué decisión
tomar sobre las tasas de interés vamos a
ver en el siguiente gráfico como la Fed
emprendió desde marzo un alza agresiva
de las tasas de interés que estaban en
el 0,125% en enero y ahora están casi en
un 5%. eso lo que buscas enfriar el dato
anual de inflación vemos que estaban
7,5% en enero Pero llegó a subir incluso
hasta el 9% desde entonces se ha visto
desde junio que los precios se han
desacelerado en diciembre ya iban en
6,5% y pues vamos a esperar como
resultado este dato muy bien y como ya
nos adelantamos con el tema de Rusia
vamos a ir a la cifra del día Claro que
sí son los siete millones de dólares
Ángela que cuestan 30 segundos de Pues
de 30 segundos de anuncios en el Super
Bowl los anunciantes Se esperan llegar a
más de 100 de espectadores este fue un
año también de cambios desde el punto de
vista comercial porque por un lado se
permitió la emisión de otros anuncios de
bebidas alcohólicas después de que
hannaher Bosch renunciara a su acuerdo
de exclusividad pero adicionalmente el
patrocinador del espectáculo de medio
tiempo cambió antes era Pepsi ahora es
Apple music después de una década de
hegemonía pues digámoslo así de Percy
Daniela gracias a usted gracias Ángela
nos vemos mañana con más claro que sí
[Música]